Have either of you been ever good at like bartering or, uh,
like I've learned to do it just because my dad was really good at it.
Like I suck at it. This is why I love Japan,
where everything is labeled and price. Because whenever I go to Thailand,
you just, you just play this dance around everything you buy, man.
It is a dance where you're just like, Oh, okay. So you're gonna, you're gonna,
you're gonna charge me that. Well, I'm gonna like say a price.
That's 10 times lower in Australia. It's like a dance that you will only dance.
If you decide to enter, it's like, you can stand back and just kind of be like,
Oh, this is how much you want. All right. Then pull your wallet out.
But then you could also be like, hold on, let me roll up my sleeves real quick.
Let's sound. But baby, think it's like,
my dad was so cause my dad's has it been like an it salesman for positive load?
He is. So this man, I don't know how the he did it,
but I remember like when I was in like a high school,
something and I wanted to buy my first guitar,
like a proper electric guitar and that he bought me like this like really nice
Epiphone guitar, which is worth like two grand or something. Yeah.
And he looked at it and he's like, so this is just the guitar. Right.
And the guy's like, yeah. It's like, can I have a chat with you mate? And any,
any talks the dude, but like back behind, like the kind of inter room.
And he's like, hold on son. I'm just gonna beat him up in the back.
Why can't he do it at the counter? I don't know. I don't know.
But he like talking to the bag. He was like, all right, let me talk.
And then I think, I think maybe like 10 minutes later, he came out,
he came out, he came out 10 minutes later and he's like, all right.
So the guitar now is 1500 any throw in a free amp. And I'm like, Whoa,
what did you say? What did you, what did you do? How did you do it? He's like,
I just talked to him mate. I'm like, no, no, no, no. Not like,
if it was that easy, then everyone would be getting deals.
It's it's not just a matter of, Oh, I just talked to him, like what,
what did you say to him? Where everyone can feel? I was like, I was like,
what did you say? Jedi mind trick. Was it like, that's technically isn't it?
Did you like inception? Like plant the seed and he's just like, it's 1500 now.
The first time I ever saw like bartering happened, I was like,
my mind was blown. I was like, wait, you can go against the price.
That's written. Yeah.
That's an option. So it wasn't.
Like we were on a school trip to New York.
It was like the first time our school ever like went to a different country.
And um, I really wanted to go to New York for school. Yeah, dude. It was chaos.
It was pure. How old were you? Ah, 16. I think.
Oh my God. Wow. He was an absolute mess, bro.
Really? The only school trips I went to was just like France at most.
That was the firms that I've ever gone to.
Bougiest one, if for some reason, for one year they never did it again.
I think they realized it was a horrible mistake. It took us to New York.
It was a mess. It was awful. It was like, I mean,
if I was a teacher that would have hated it, I had a great time. But yeah,
it was, I remember it was very expensive, but um,
we stayed in like really sketchy motels.
I can talk about it more after the story, but we were, we were basically like,
I really wanted converse because obviously when you're like 15, 16,
you see the and like American, you like yo Hong Kong.
So I went to the store and my friend was with me and he was only,
he was in the year above me. And I was like, man, I want to get these.
But I've only got like 30 bucks left and that 40 bucks, he was like, Oh, I'll,
I'll ask him if we can do it for 30. He's like 17 bartering with him.
And then eventually he said, I'll give you for 30. If you give me a $2 tip.
And I'm like, is that okay? Are you allowed to do that?
I don't know if he's the owner of law, but that's what he got it down to.
And I was so impressed when I went home to the UK. I tried to do it,
but immediately all the stores are like.
No, wait, what stores I'd go to?
Like in America or the UK in America [inaudible] store.
I think it was like in a mall.
It's like an independent store. Maybe. I think that's why I got away with it.
So I went to like a supermarket in the UK, go to the thing.
I'm going to test
five pounds and a little too much for this [inaudible] you're selling me this
Kellogg's Krispy. Kremes for like how much I'll be like, you know,
it's a little, three pounds, a little expensive, two 50. I'll do 50 50.
No, no, no. I'm like, Oh, okay. that. I've never tried it again for awhile,
but I like going to places where you can do it. Cause I like,
I like trying to do it. I don't know.
I don't, I don't, I don't know how,
like I probably could do it if I really wanted to,
but I'm always just so afraid to do it as well. Cause I don't know how like, um,
I don't know. Cause with that kind of stuff,
if you're not coming in with confidence, you're basically.
There's no way you're going to win it.
You need to come in with like a winning mentality coming in with like the
biggest Dick energy. I'm like, I can do it. It just takes so much energy.
But whenever in a you're in a place like Thailand,
that's like 90% of the stores you go to and you just want a store where you pay
the price that the originally asked for and just not have to like do this mini
game every time.
I remember I watched like the,
I think I mentioned him on the YouTube rep series.
He just videos about Prague covers like taxi scams.
I was in Prague and I had a taxi and I was like,
this is like in the simulations, this is exactly what he spoke about.
Cause they were trying to charge her. What he said was being overcharged.
I remember I was with my maintenance taxi. I'm like, no,
no I've seen the YouTube video. I've got this. That I was like,
I'm not paying that. That's too much.
But eventually we got to like half the price. It was wow.
You're supposed to be like, he like 50 euros for like, uh,
the equivalent in check money for like, um,
like it was supposed to be like half that it was like only like a 20 minute,
like 15 minute journey where I was like, no, I've seen the simulations.
I know this is right.
And there's YouTube channels of dudes who go around India like bartering.
Oh yeah.
I can imagine bartering in India is just like next level. That's like,
that's like expert mode, man. That's literally isn't it looks like.
A reality TV show with every purchase. The guy's like I'm walking away.
I'm going, I'm not getting in your taxi. And then they're like.
[Inaudible] please, sir.